here now with reaction the president's
attorney Jay Sekulow quick on that the
bigger picture is we have real collusion
uncovered we have a real quid pro quo
and once again it's a boomerang right
yes so you know this is the ongoing
pattern and practice of trying to
basically shred the Constitution so what
California tried to do was add a
requirements of the Constitution so that
if you didn't produce your tax returns
you do not appear on the ballot we
challenged that in federal court the
court indicated last week that they were
likely to rule in our favor the ruling
just came down the presidential tact and
transparency and accountability act is
declared unconstitutional it violates
the freedom of association the
presidential qualification clause and
equal protections of the law the court
then issued the following order the
defendants that is the state of
California are enjoined from enforcing
provisions of the presidential tax
transparency and accountability Act
requiring candidates for president to
disclose their tax return as a condition
of appearing in California's
presidential primary ballot now I'll tie
this right in to Shawn what we are what
you had mentioned in your monologue and
that is this issue of the president
calling heads of state regarding this
ongoing investigation of how the
counter-intelligence matter is James
Comey which should have called it based
on his previous statements but called it
an investigation how that started and
here's what we now have we my colleague
professor Harry Hutchison who's a senior
policy analyst for the American Center
for Law and Justice also one of our
senior lawyers produced a document today
which includes reference to two treaties
I'm holding them in my hand right now
these two treaties this one is with
Australia the other treaty is with the
Ukraine it is entitled treaty with
Ukraine on mutual legal assistance in
criminal matters same with the matter
involving Australia treaty with
Australia on mutual assistance in
criminal matters the president when he
called made calls on behalf of the
Attorney General to encourage
cooperation regarding how this entire
counterintelligence fraud took place he
was not only within his constitutional
rights to do it but as Harry Hutchinson
points out it was his constitutional
obligations to engage in this
I because the presidents required to
faithfully execute the laws of the
United States and the Constitution
that's what he's doing but what's
happening right now is individuals and
this is what we have to understand those
that are so opposed to what the
president's doing on any front are
trying to weaponize the Constitution to
make the execution of it basically
illegal and when you look at these two
treaties and by the way there's other
treaties with other countries as well
when you look at the phone calls and you
look at the history of what's happened
here first it was quid pro quo well then
they look at the transcript no quid pro
quo then it was the president's asking
for inquiries to be made on various
matters oh well I guess you have the
right to do that under the Constitution
and according to these treaties which is
now an affirmative obligation then it
was a cover-up a cover-up of what the
document was released so here's what
you've got at the end of this right now
Shawn where it sits right now not only
did we win in California and we will win
all of this nonsense as well but really
what's at stake for the American people
is the United States Constitution that
is what is at stake here all right Jay
Sekulow the counsel for the president
chief counsel American Center for Law
and Justice Jay thank you for your time
again tonight